college students have had to contend
with a lot of changes since the outbreak
began from online classes to virtual
graduations at the beginning of the year
students were preparing to graduate into
the strongest job market in decades for
all of us our entire worlds are being
flipped upside down now as more than 25
million US workers have filed for
unemployment soon-to-be graduates are
facing a newly competitive job market
they're walking into a hurricane
so as the class of 2020 prepares to into
the workforce
what challenges lie ahead and how can
they adapt to this new normal Samantha
Carter is a senior at the University of
Illinois at Chicago majoring in
psychology in March her in-person
internship she needed in order to
graduate was cancelled due to the
coronavirus I was truly terrified at
first my first thought was am I gonna be
able to graduate UIC psychology
department has decided to make
exceptions regarding internship
requirements which will allow students
like Carter to graduate on time but now
she faces a new challenge her post
graduation job is as a runner with
concert promotion company Live Nation
the original plan was to obviously do
that and then go to grad school in about
two or three years but now honestly I
have no idea because everything's just
changing so rapidly
Live Nation says they are working
through the short-term impacts for this
year's concert season and they look
forward to ramping shows back up as soon
as they can with large events being
postponed and canceled nationwide Carter
says she may look for a different job
temporarily and is considering grad
school sooner than planned it is really
scary to know that you know I have this
degree I might go to grad school and get
another degree and I have them but am I
able to use them the National
Association of Colleges and employers
has been trekking employer hiring
responses regarding the impact of the
virus since much traditionally we're not
seeing revoked offers that is that is
extremely unusual in in a in a standard
college year but the latest data shows
an increasing number of employers
surveyed are revoking full-time offers
and internships are at risk to 20
percent of employers surveyed
revoking offers Dow Jones which
publishes the Wall Street Journal has
postponed most of its internships until
next year
Edwin Koch says a critical aspect of the
internship is developing a cultural
connection between the intern and the
company I'm not sure how well you can
measure the cultural thing as companies
increasingly shift to virtual recruiting
job seekers will have to learn how to
stand out in a virtual setting and in a
newly packed field students who
graduated in 2009 experienced a similar
challenge when they entered the toughest
job market in decades when the college
recruiting market started to open up in
2010 the 2009 grads would not treat it
as new college graduates they were if
they were lumped in with the employees
who grown unquote had experienced the
few studies that have been done shows
that when you graduate in a period like
this the ramifications the negative
ramifications
unfortunately continue with you for most
of your employment career the recruiting
numbers are changing by the day but
coach says the when it comes to hiring
or revoking offers many employers are
taking a wait-and-see attitude that's
when we saw a significant change in
terms of some clients ramping up Patrick
Burrell is the CEO of true blue a
recruiting and staffing agency clients
that we saw just falling through the
floor in terms of their volumes were
hospitality tie providers hotel clients
our Burrell says that when companies are
scaling down temporary workers are often
the first to get cut but that they're
often the first part of the workforce to
recover after a recession employers use
temporary workers to augment their
workforce I wouldn't be surprised if we
saw employers using
temporary workers more than they have in
the past on the try before you buy type
of arrangement
Edwin Koch suggests getting into the
workforce is the first step the student
would always ask is it is it better to
take any old job or is it better to wait
the employers that I lose with on those
presentations would always tell that it
was better to put something on your
resume it take what you can get even if
it is volunteering as two and there is
no income associated with it despite the
outlook students like kata are adapting
to this changing markets really just
allowed me to open my mind a little bit
more the possibilities and realize that
you know just because you have a plan
doesn't mean that that's set in stone
that's exactly how it's gonna happen
you